Transcription: Ludovica Da Lozzo
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour, je vais vous parler
d’Amélie Beaury-Saurel,
une femme artiste
qui a changé les paradigmes,
puisque c’est de cela qu’on parle :
la façon dont on peut, par son œuvre,
changer la façon de penser d’une époque.
Ça n’a l’air de rien mais être artiste
pour une femme à la fin du 19ème siècle,
c’est quelque chose de tout à fait
étrange et incongru.
Ce n’est pas normal.
Ce qui est normal, c’est au fond,
pour un artiste homme,
de prendre comme sujet de peinture
les femmes, les représenter
et les transformer à sa guise
en héroïnes, prostituées,
bourgeoises un peu rêveuses.
C’est ce qui se passe en temps normal.
Mais les femmes vont vouloir prendre
leur destin en mains et devenir artistes.
C’est un parcours semé d’embûches
parce que l’enseignement artistique
leur est fermé.
L’École des Beaux-Arts, en particulier,
n’accueille les femmes qu’à partir de 1897
et encore, ne les accueille
à plein titre qu’en 1903
en leur permettant
d’assister aux concours
et de faire toute une scolarité.
Et d’ailleurs, preuve
que ce n’est pas évident,
c’est que quand les femmes vont avoir le
droit d’accéder à l’École des Beaux-Arts,
les hommes élèves dans cette école
vont manifester
aux cris de : « À bas les femmes ! »
Amélie Beaury-Saurel est le produit
de cette époque
et elle va devoir chercher
une école privée pour apprendre l’art.
Elle va aller à l’Académie Julian
qui souvent prend des élèves étrangères,
du monde entier,
qui vont vouloir s’imposer à Paris, qui
est la capitale internationale de l’art.
Elle va y connaître plusieurs femmes,
dont certaines vont devenir assez connues
parce qu’elles ont écrit des mémoires
en particulier,
comme Marie Bashkirtseff
qui parlera d’elle d’ailleurs.
Donc on est dans un contexte
où il faut se battre pour exister.
Beaury-Saurel va d’abord sortir
de cette école
et puis elle va petit à petit
exposer dans les salons.
Elle commence en 1874, qui est l’année
qui voit les Impressionnistes sortir
du système officiel des salons.
Le salon, c’est l’exposition annuelle
où on est sélectionné et où on présente
une ou plusieurs œuvres.
Et elle va devenir un peu plus célèbre
à partir de 1880.
On connaît assez peu sa vie.
On sait qu’elle épouse Rodolphe Julian
qui est le directeur de cette fameuse
Académie Julian
mais elle ne se contente pas
d’être « la femme de » :
elle va vraiment avoir
une personnalité artistique
et aussi une personnalité d’enseignante
puisqu’elle va d’abord prendre en main
la classe des femmes
et ensuite elle va diriger l’école
jusqu’à sa mort en 1924.
Cette artiste, on la perçoit mieux
à travers ses œuvres
parce qu’elle ne s’est jamais
exprimée publiquement,
politiquement
sur son art.
Je vais vous montrer les trois œuvres
qui sont conservées
au Musée des Augustins.
D’abord, la plus célèbre :
« Dans le bleu ».
« Dans le bleu » c’est un titre
qui évoque un peu le blues,
qui évoque un peu la mélancolie.
C’est un tableau qui ne représente
rien de spécial à première vue :
une femme rêveuse.
Mais, quand on regarde
un peu plus attentivement,
on analyse plusieurs choses.
D’abord, les volutes de fumée,
c’est qu’il y a une cigarette.
Ensuite, il y a une tasse de café.
Or, la cigarette et le café, ce sont
vraiment des passe-temps masculins.
D’ailleurs, une femme bien née ne peut pas
se présenter dans un café.
Ce n’est pas possible : un bistrot, c’est
un lieu fermé  aux femmes à cette époque.
Et surtout cette femme
ne fait rien de spécial :
elle rêvasse, elle attend,
elle est dans son monde
et ça c’est particulier.
C’est de faire de cette simple vision
un véritable tableau.
Ça, c’est nouveau.
Ça rappelle un peu
les mots de Virginia Woolf
qui dans « Une chambre à soi » a dit
que la femme artiste, la femme écrivain,
devait se créer un monde à elle
avec son espace et surtout le temps,
le temps pour créer.
Le temps est essentiel et dans ce tableau,
on est face à une question du temps.
On est un regard de femme
qui est plongé sur une autre femme,
qui prend son temps,
qui est dans son monde.
Ce pastel a été donné
par Alphonse de Rothschild
qui était de la célèbre famille
des banquiers Rothschild
mais qui l’a fait comme un encouragement
pour que cette œuvre entre dans un musée
dès l’année de sa création, en 1894.
Quelques années plus tard, en 1899,
Amélie Beaury-Saurel reprend
le même thème, le même personnage,
cette fois dans un format portrait.
On retrouve exactement les mêmes symboles,
les mêmes marqueurs :
la tasse de café,
la cigarette,
dans un style
beaucoup plus esquissé,
beaucoup plus fusain.
Il n’y a que deux taches de couleur :
l’une qu’on voit bien - la violette -
l’autre qu’on ne voit pas
sur cette reproduction -
la touche de braise de la cigarette.
Même chose sur le contexte.
Ce qu’il y a, c’est que
quand on reconnaît cette femme,
on l’identifie aux photos qu’on connaît
d’Amélie Beaury-Saurel
et il s’agit bien d’un autoportrait.
Il y a vraiment une volonté
de se mettre en scène
de manière un peu militante,
un peu revendicatrice et de dire :
« Voilà j’existe, je suis une personne,
je suis une femme artiste.
Je me présente devant vous,
j’ai le talent.
Je veux être moi-même
le sujet de mon tableau. »
Et c’est en ça que l’œuvre est moderne.
Moderne, pas comme les Impressionnistes
qui vont découvrir une autre façon
d’appliquer les touches,
mais moderne par son sujet,
par sa façon de montrer,
comme le voulait Charles Baudelaire
qui était critique d’art et poète,
de montrer la peinture de la vie moderne.
Là on a affaire à une vision
assez sensible du temps :
elle capte l’esprit du temps,
elle est moderne
et elle montre finalement
cette simple femme
qui prend le temps d’être elle-même.
Le nu est évidemment un enjeu particulier.
Dans cette académie de femmes,
Beaury-Saurel va vraiment
traiter le nu de manière originale.
Qu’est ce que le nu ?
Le nu, c’est la base
de l’enseignement académique.
On commence souvent par dessiner
des statues antiques
puis on dessine devant des modèles nus.
Modèles nus hommes et femmes
mais les modèles nus femmes
ont très mauvaise réputation :
elles sont considérées,
comme les actrices de l’époque,
presque comme des prostituées.
Les artistes hommes vont abuser
et profiter de ces femmes.
La nudité à cette époque - on est à la fin
du 19ème siècle début du 20ème siècle -
elle n’est que tolérée et elle
est tolérée dans certains contextes,
c’est-à-dire que
quand on est dans la mythologie,
dans l’histoire grecque ou romaine,
c’est tellement ancien qu’on peut
imaginer les dieux grecs nus.
Quand on veut montrer une scène
de la vie moderne,
la nudité n’est pas acceptée
parce qu’elle met en danger la société.
On se souvient de l’Olympia de Manet
qui a fait scandale,
justement pour avoir montré
le nu dans le moderne,
alors qu’une Vénus comme celle de Cabanel
pouvait être montrée, même si elle est
infiniment peut-être plus impudique
que toutes les œuvres contemporaines.
Mais ici, il n’y a rien d’impudique,
c’est vraiment une femme artiste
qui se penche sur une autre femme modèle
et va la montrer de manière naturelle,
sans jugement,
avec un regard neutre,
avec une certaine empathie, certes,
mais elle va surtout montrer que,
derrière un nu, il y a une personnalité,
il y a une femme, il y a quelqu’un
qui incarne vraiment cette personne.
Donc ce n’est pas du tout un nu
fait pour exciter l’imagination.
C’est un nu qui est composé quand même,
on voit que cette femme s’appuie
à une branche,
qu’elle a un drapé.
Il y a tout le côté étude ;
ça permet à l’artiste
de bien étudier l’anatomie
qui est quand même la base
de l’enseignement.
Mais ensuite, elle fait une œuvre d’art
parce que c’est quand même un tableau
assez grand et assez fort.
D’ailleurs, il faut aussi penser
qu’à cette époque,
la photographie est en train de s’imposer.
Donc quand on choisit de représenter
la personne humaine,
non par la photographie
mais par la peinture,
alors qu’on pourrait
prendre un photographe,
c’est un choix,
soit qu’on veut donner encore plus
de statut, d’importance à la personne,
soit au contraire qu’on veut travailler
avec encore plus de liberté.
Et la peinture permet cette liberté.
Il ne faut pas oublier que la peinture
est un choix à cette époque.
Ces trois tableaux sont des pastels.
Le pastel, c’est technique.
On dit souvent : « Les femmes vont
faire des choses petites,
des aquarelles, des pastels. »
Mais ces pastels-là, d’abord
c’est une belle technique,
une technique difficile à manier,
avec un crayon gras.
Et ensuite, ce sont
des œuvres très monumentales :
un format presque grandeur nature,
un mètre cinquante ou plus,
selon les dimensions des œuvres.
Il y a donc beaucoup d’ambition.
Ce ne sont pas des petites œuvres,
ce sont des œuvres fortes,
des œuvres qui frappent l’imagination
quand on les voit.
On pourrait se demander
face à ces œuvres,
face à la qualité de l’artiste,
pourquoi elle n’est pas plus connue.
Elle n’est pas plus connue
pour plusieurs raisons.
D’abord il n’y avait pas beaucoup de
femmes artistes dans l’histoire ancienne
donc elles sont peu nombreuses.
On ne s’intéressait pas tellement à elles,
ça ne fait que quelques années
qu’on s’y intéresse vraiment.
Ensuite, et ça c’est le mauvais
côté de la célébrité,
c’est le côté people, c’est-à-dire
qu’on accepte les femmes artistes
quand elles ont souffert,
quand elles portent les stigmates
de leur vie douloureuse.
Frida Kahlo, Camille Claudel,
Artemisia Gentileschi
ce sont des femmes qui ont souffert
et qui ont souffert de la part des hommes.
On n’a rien de ça pour
Amélie Beaury-Saurel.
Comme je vous l’ai dit,
on connaît peu sa vie.
Elle semble avoir été heureuse
avec son mari.
Du coup, il n’y a pas cet aspect-là.
Il n’y a que ses œuvres pour revendiquer
cette cause féminine.
C’est un aspect possible
du fait qu’elle ne soit pas connue.
Elle n’a pas une grande cote
sur le marché de l’art:
elle n’avait pas produit énormément.
Il y a peu d’œuvres dans les musées.
Quand j’ai eu à acheter ces œuvres,
elles n’ont pas coûté très très cher,
finalement, au Musée des Augustins,
15 000 et 18 000.
Finalement, on peut se constituer
une collection de cette artiste
de manière assez raisonnable.
Le Musée des Augustins est un musée
qui a de très nombreux
chefs-d’œuvres d’artistes femmes,
et pourrait vraiment en faire un axe
de ses collections.
Le Musée est fermé à l’heure actuelle
mais en tout cas les œuvres,
quand elles sont présentées au public,
le public réagit très favorablement.
Il est extrêmement sensibilisé
à cette artiste
et je pense que chacun
ressent une véritable émotion
et ressent une forme d’appropriation
devant les qualités de ces pastels.
J’espère que vous les découvrirez quand
le Musée réouvrira après les travaux.
En tout cas, « Dans le bleu » est
une œuvre vraiment très frappante
et qui, je pense, va vous impressionner.
Vous allez vous vous imprégner
de ses qualités
et entrer vraiment dans l’esprit
d’une femme artiste
de la fin du 19ème siècle.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)